talked about Xbox in some Realms
sometimes appearing to me as complacent
um I think that's set in when we saw the
major delay last year it's it felt like
a reset for fans when they said all
right right before the Big Summer
showcase Starfield redfall delayed it
felt like that was everyone just
Gathering themselves one last time to
wait because we all agreed you know what
if XBox wants to hit that PlayStation
level which we always talk about we want
to hit the PlayStation premium quality
we're gonna have to wait and when you
wait all that time and you think about
all the times we saw redfall between now
and then for it to just be announced now
I imagine it was a feature plan that got
cut it's a very bad look and it reminds
me of again what I said on on Duke which
was that kind of I call it the silver
metal specialist like it just kind of
they're just love in second place and
they just they don't mind they're like
yeah we're doing well enough for